do you remember a bunch of years ago one
of the soda companies I think was
Coca-Cola they put people's names on
cans and you just would go remember just
for a while it was just a marketing
thing I mean you could write things on
cans
um uh that that capture the spirit of
what cheers means I mean you could write
cheers but but you can actually write
statements like this is for this is
because I this cheers because I love you
choose because congratulations just like
you can write those things on the cans
and you can start to do it in product
that's that's narrative you're starting
to tell your story through your product
also the way you talk about
um your jobs quite frankly you know if
if I ask the average employee at ABI if
I were to sit next to them on a plane
and say what do you do the dreaded
question right what do you do oh I'm a
marketing manager at Anheuser-Busch
okay
right
um what it what would it mean if they
would actually say something at high at
a higher level than that oh um I get to
help find new ways to bring people
together to celebrate each other and
take care of each other that's amazing
how do you do that I'm actually a
marketing manager at Anheuser-Busch
right where when narrative starts to
seep into the into the culture people
start talking about the cause before
they start talking about their jobs
you know
um uh
Marines if you ask if you ask somebody
in this in the Army what do you do to
say oh I'm I work in the Infantry blah
blah blah if you ask Marine what do you
do this I'm a Marine
that's what comes first it's the global
right it's it's the membership
um I think I think every time you go
give a every time you show up on
television and every time you you know
you give a public speech goes back to
that story of um Phil Knight and I'm not
proposing you you know you tell Phil
Knight Phil Knight type story but the
point is is like you're gonna go in
Squawk Box and they're going to say
they're going to ask you a question and
your ability to talk about your cause
not you know sometimes the literal words
but sometimes in interpretive words
um and how you imagine the company
coming to and what bold means you know
what what dreaming big means and sharing
some of those dreams and like we're a
company that says we dream big let me
tell you what we mean by let me tell you
some of the dreams we have
and you can talk about how you're you're
changing your incentive structures you
can talk about how you're challenging
old Notions of business you can talk
about how the world is changing and
you're not going to follow the change
you're going to lead the change this is
all narrative and it all is based on the
same the same core so to answer your
question there's no right answer but if
you listen to all of the different
narratives they all have a flavor
you know it's like somebody asked before
like what what is how am I an effective
preacher if you go watch any video I've
made and if you go read any book that
I've written you can you can feel that
there's a theme
that theme is always there and people
are smart people can discern themes and
so the more consistent you are in all
the different ways you bring it to life
people start to understand what that
theme is
like Disney it's always there